close your left eye and stare at the X
with your right eye now don't look away
move your phone closer maybe further
away until my head appears to vanish you
have just found your blind spot the
place on your retina where nerves pass
through on their way to the brain you
can't see anything there but blind spots
don't create big obvious dark missing
regions in our vision because our brains
fill them in after the fact with
whatever color or pattern it thinks
should be there what makes its fantasm
really freaky though is that we believe
in it more than we believe in what's
actually in front of us when people are
shown something like this and they're
blind spot is right here the brain fills
it in so this is what they see if then
asked which Circle contains just
parallel lines the brain does not push
us to trust what's actually out there
most people choose the parallel lines
their brains have created with a guess
over the ones that are fully available
to them seeing is believing but
sometimes just making stuff up is super
believing